[Music]
[Applause]
texas longhorns surprised a lot of
people yesterday as they got arch
manning in the running with alabama
georgia maybe
ole miss a couple other programs in
there felt like it was down to three and
it turns out that it's going to be the
longhorns but he doesn't get there until
next year kirk bowles has been around a
long time austin american statesman one
of the great columnists in america
last time you were this excited kirk
about a quarterback coming to the
longhorns was when
that would be 2002 the name of vince
young that you might recall
and uh you know it's weird arch manny
got a perfect rating from the recruiting
websites then the only other two were
vince young and quinn ewers and they all
have longhorn ties how amazing is that
quinn ewers is uh place card holder here
i'm guessing
yeah i don't think he would have left
ohio state uh i don't know if he's
running away from cj stroud but you know
i don't think he's here at texas to you
know sit behind hudson cards so i don't
and i don't know if he's just holding
the seat warm or not dan because you
know he was the number one quarterback
in his recruiting class a couple years
ago so you know he seems like he has the
it factor but he hadn't thrown a pass in
college football yet so how do we really
know
what role do you think did it play that
arch was going to go to texas knowing
texas is going to be in the sec in a
couple of years
you know
he strikes me as a kind of guy he
doesn't run from competition and you
want to play at the highest level so i'm
sure that was probably a factor but just
the fact that he picked texas with all
those you know family ties to tennessee
and ole miss and could have gone just
anywhere he wanted you know it speaks
volumes for this guy's character you
know i think a lot of fact that
you know
sark was a quarterback at byu you know
he's played the position he and you know
kirby's smart not to
you know
throw any shade on him obviously the
national championship winning coach but
he's a defensive guy so was uh
uh
yeah so i think i think that spoke to
arch manning as well dan can you remove
the manning family from arch if he's
arch smith
is he still
the number one recruiter how much does
that play into it that you know the
pedigree the family history well that's
got to play a big role i think just the
fact that you know we're talking about
the first family of
football in america when you when you
get down to we're talking about you know
college football nfl royalty and i think
that uh you know definitely plays a
factor but you know you talk to his high
school coach at israel newman you know
yeah i don't know if if coaches want to
coach this guy or adopt him
in some ways it almost sounds too good
to be true
you mentioned sarc sort of a quarterback
whisperer i just want to know about sark
the head coach because it's one thing
that you can coach quarterbacks i want
to know if you can coach a football team
well we haven't seen any evidence of
that yet as head coach i mean he's got a
51-42 record and he's been at some
powerhouse schools with washington
southern cal in texas and uh you know
southern cal hadn't been the same since
pete carroll left you know washington he
overtook a program that was you know
kind of in dire straits and you could
say the same for texas so but you look
at the resources that those schools have
and you figure he's got everything he
should have
and that jury is very much out of the
room yet then when you lose six straight
games you blow one half time lead after
the other and go four and five and seven
so yeah i don't think that book has been
closely been written yet
who had a better off season texas a m or
texas
i tell you what it sure seems like
sharks win in the off season you know
finished fifth in the nation in
recruiting it's not to the caliber of
texas a m but texas a m has been able to
sell that sec they're already there
they're playing in there they beat
alabama last year texas will get that
chance obviously in week two but i i
can't imagine stark having a better off
season than he's had to finish fifth in
the nation recruiting to land this guy
the number one uh prospect and all the
recruiting it's those damn pesky games
that get in the play you know just had
the off season you know start may claim
the national championship name image and
likeness how is that how big is that
with texas we know how important it is
with a m and alabama some of these other
schools we haven't heard about texas at
least nationally yeah i think nick saban
may have mentioned that once or twice
this summer or two about how big nia was
it it has changed the
the whole college landscape and change
the college athletics as we know it i
think and texas is going to be right
there with it you got a pancake factory
offering 50 000 to offensive linemen and
and they could use some offensive
linemen here and sorry got 15 o-line and
d-linemen you know in this last
recruiting class so he knows this isn't
a one-man show i mean you look at peyton
manning he went to tennessee he didn't
win the national championship t martin
comes around next year and wins it so
you know you better have that strong
supporting cast
they're going to be a heavy player
nationally year to year
in nil and bijan robinson
may be the best tailback in college
football he's driving around a
lamborghini uh i gotta figure it out oh
whoa he's gone
exactly
and uh
you know art manny may get the whole
dealership i don't know
thank you i don't think you can
overstate how big it is in recruiting
where did you stand when you heard texas
was going to join the sec
oh i think it was kind of long overdue
and maybe they don't quite fit the whole
profile of these
strong state flagship schools but in
more rural america than in texas so a
lot of people would say texas culture
doesn't fit but they want to play with
the big boys and they haven't been able
to do that and clearly they're not ready
you know to play in the sec but getting
the type of player that arch manning is
gets them a little bit closer but hey
you got to see some w's on the field too
obviously but no no i support it good to
talk to you again kirk hope you're doing
well got a lot to write about although
you got to wait a little bit to write
about but
should be interesting thank you for
joining us thank you dan have a great
summer kirk bowles austin american
statesman sports columnist